Called anemia, what should I do? It is it said that one should not take
Iron supplements, so this person is talking about my blog, I think so my blog post I wrote the article anemia
What should I do? Should not take iron supplements if your ferritin levels are elevated my last blood test show that I had very high
ferritin should I discontinue taking the irons?
Did you said me your last blood test? Was your ferritin levels elevated beyond functional range?
The ranges that I put in that article are when they be on
Lab range, so if your ferritin levels were not beyond
Lab range that I would say no still keep taking the iron supplements if there were way elevated beyond lab range then we'd have to think about that
The reason why I say don't take fair don't take iron if your ferritin levels are elevated is because
highly elevated ferritin levels are also a sign of
Inflammation and we don't want to add to that inflammation
So you look at other things as well in that progression of understanding
But just in general if a person has low red blood cell count and other sides of anemia
But their ferritin levels are through the roof then we have to consider backing off on the iron. So I would want to look at that
That level if you're still within lab range but outside of functional range that I'd say we're going to continue to take the iron if you're way beyond
Lab range that say your ferritin levels are a thousand that I would say we're not going to take iron
We don't because iron can cause more inflammation. So that's how we would analyze that